the Joe Rogan experience but whatever it
but but they would go at him faked me
out when Patton Oswalt's wife died
somebody asked me sends him a thing with
his dead wife photoshopped in the
Ghostbusters poster I like using your
shitty on cuz bit all the my own thing
was you not you don't know what's funny
so don't if I tell you you know there's
that whole joke thief [ __ ] there and I'm
like listen I I was there and also I
know comedy and I know better than you
jerk-off at home so if I tell you just
nothing I know better
I'll just put it that way maybe that's
arrogant but I just been doing it for 20
years and you never had the balls get
onstage so I think I just know better
there you're finding when someone's not
even here I started some jokes tea fight
no one has any idea [ __ ] yourself right
guys is when I defended Amy right Amy
and I had people like lecture and I'm
like don't listen who don't presume to
tell me [ __ ] but but they're outraged
Dave but the same as the social jihadis
they all think they get the same reason
I became a comic mom I could do that so
they all but at least I did it
you know if you get on stage and do it
I'll give it to it but these people
think they can do your job but hold on a
second in their defense yeah they're
looking at a film that shows time after
time bits that daddy made specifically
[ __ ] her because she said I play a
racist Republican right the little
YouTube video where they took movies
[ __ ] the show which by the way she
doesn't write the show it was ridiculous
and it was exactly what the [ __ ]
sjw's did to me
where they don't like your they think
you have an agenda they got to destroy
so they create this [ __ ] a you know
it's like a smear job there were bits
that were exactly the same dude relax
relax
I drank too I think man night rose and
you're talking me this way I do I know
this but you run through the wall and
Kurt shaped and break in touch so a a
caveman nitro you but you're you're
arguing against someone who's not even
here why they are going at me that is
what the problem with what you're saying
is they have evidence they're looking at
one bit and it's exactly the same if I
look at the evidence and
come to a different conclusion right
let's go with my conclusion because I
was there that's not enough to convince
someone oh just trust me you think isn't
that like some authoritative Sheriff
type [ __ ] just trust me but trust me I'm
watching this video I'm watching these
jokes they're being repeated you're
saying just trust me talk I'm talking
about sketches he's got claims rejection
which is nonsense I was in the room
I guess the looking cop of the room with
blood [ __ ] but that doesn't mean no one
watch my TV stuff sorry stop that
doesn't mean anything because the the
bits still got on the air see what I'm
saying like you might not even happen
intentional it doesn't matter that's
what you have to say that's not what you
say that no no joke you can't but you
can't say that these people don't have
actual examples of the same bits over
and over again if there's if it's
parallel thinking that's fine but it has
to be absolutely it but you didn't
really see this this the whole thing
about this is you're saying I'm confused
but if they see the evidence right you
have to like you have to be real clear
confrontational when you're when you're
handling some point but dude I won't
first of all number one the larger issue
is I never should be on social media
talking to any of these [ __ ] at all
complaining I don't owe any of you
anybody listening if you have a question
or a judgement I don't owe you an
explanation for [ __ ] I understand I know
where the [ __ ] you got the idea that I
do so I was wrong
that I even [ __ ] at any answer at all
because you have people hey joke thief
really that's the word about me that I'm
a joke thief from some know-nothing and
it's they just want to see I'll talk
back to them you did steal it and you
gotta explain how this was a parallel
thing yeah well there's gonna be many
times I did I know but alone people
haven't heard it and you're blurting it
out like that
someone's arguing you in the room I'm
just free there's always a pro rape guys
here's one thing I wanna make clear I am
pro rape
Ray's apologist I'm Pro reap I really
apologize for one thing like yeah I'm
gonna bring up why this why I was
getting [ __ ] I'm getting [ __ ] for
defending a me from these alright dress
I understand but it's also because
you're confronting them like you're
you're confrontational yeah I like so I
like being on line and also it seemed
like no of no consequence to me I'm like
I got all this [ __ ] going on I can with
one hand sit here and answer your dumb
[ __ ] I was like cocky I understand I
understand but what I'm saying is from
the perspective of someone who's a
stand-up fan my hand is trembling for my
dress that's crazy it's got some serious
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is in this 270
milligrams caffeine you probably have
some coffee earlier - yes so you do
Twitter like me where you think it's
almost like the candy crush of words and
then before you know it I just pissed
off uber or some [ __ ] listen I'm
speaking as a nitro caveman - you're
ready to start smoking though a person
who's a fan of comedy like and I am a
fan of comedy when I see like if I if I
was never a stand-up and I saw this all
going down and I was a kurt metzger fan
I would want Kurt Metzger to explain to
me what happened I would want you your
your specific words on this because you
were a writer over there right so like
as a fan I would want to know I think
Kurt Metzger is a hilarious create new
comedian I want to know how this
happened my sketches were so for you to
say it defensively to brush it off and
say that you know better than you know
I'll tell you why because I the way
someone would come at me would it be
rude immediately like who gonna be this
way so say you're a very defensive well
as soon as I have somebody coming at me
a certain way like just your natural
mode right yeah you know naturally
you
[Applause]